what's inherently more about gay
marriage
it is anti-life in his anti-vital Maybe
anti-life
it does not produce kids and the
marriage itself it should be illegal for
two straight people who decide not to
have kids get married no I believe they
should still get married but then that's
anti anti-life right
it is not anti-life in the same way but
they're not reproducing just like two
gay people don't reproduce
whoa I get what you're saying basically
are you talking about people who know
they're infertile and yet they want to
get married is that what you're saying
any example of that one too you're
saying ban infernal people from getting
married even straight couples
no because at the end of the day they
can still adopt kids and raise them gay
people can adopt kids right I don't
believe they should there's no recent
reports about a gay couple this is what
you call just ping-ponging from one
topic to another